now more devastation to tell you about
this time on the east coast as ida made
its way out leaving tornadoes torrential
downpour and flooding today folks in new
york and other parts of the northeast
are assessing the damage homes in new
jersey are now piles of rubble after a
tornado swept through the southern part
of the state and last night for the
first time ever the national weather
service issued a flash flood emergency
for new york city the entire subway
system as you can see shut down
overnight as water gushed in today new
york governor kathy hokel talked about
the aftermath
we have no choice my friends
the future we spoke about in dire terms
that future is now it's happening we're
losing life
lives we're losing property and we
cannot continue on this path so that is
the sense of urgency that i'm bringing
to this situation
governor hokul went on to say she's
working closely with president joe biden
to try and get fema funds
and if you'd like to help survivors you
can donate to the american red cross
disaster relief the website is
redcross.org you can also give them a
phone call their number you see under on
the screen 1-800 red cross and to make a
ten dollar donation you can text red
cross to nine zero triple nine this
information is available on our website